aujourd'hui il n'y a pas il y a pas un
magasin qui n'a pas quelque chose à ne
pas se reprocher et la faire bétoni moi
je la vivais au quotidien j'ai mangé de
faire mourir une mère de famille
d'accord parce que j'avais mariné des
bavettes qui étaient qui étaient permis
depuis plus de 10 jours on est d'accord
de la chair à saucisse que je faisais
chipolatas que des morceaux de viande
qui trempaient dans un liquide visqueux
dans un bac de la merguez des araignées
le célèbre morceau qu'on appelle
l'araignée qui était moisi et que je
broyais parce que la pâte du gain
c'était je veux dire pour faire du
billet ils sont prêts à faire n'importe
quoi et moi j'ai fait une dépression
nerveuse et c'est pour ça que j'ai écrit
ce livre et j’allerte les consommateurs
j'arrête les personnes aujourd'hui à
faire très attention quand ils vont
chercher un morceau de viande dans la
grande distribution ce serait passé dans
un magasin mais ce qui va se passer
relativement partout
et ça je l'ai vécu j'ai les preuves la
salmonelle la salmonelle qui était dans
les rayons je supplie en de mes
collègues j'étais en congé ce jour-là je
supplie un de mes collègues de
de retirer le produit c'est dans le
livre
et le chef ne voulait pas les retirer à
vous entendre ce que vous dites votre
témoignage ça veut dire que c'est fait
sciemment c'est à dire qu'ils savent ils
ont connaissance de cause qu'ils mettent
en danger des gens
vous savez que on a loue des primes aux
personnes aujourd'hui on a lu des primes
au chef ou chez moi il y a perte
d'accord plus la prime sera grosse
et je veux dire on fait n'importe quoi
pour vraiment pour pour avoir le moins
de perles des derniers scandales
alimentaires regardez dans ce reportage
documentaire de capital regardez ce
manque d'hygiène comporte des risques
bien entendu
plus inquiétant encore selon les
inspecteurs l'état de ce hachoir
il va contaminer tout ce qui passe
dedans ce hachoir pourrait devenir un
nid à salmonelle à Listeria ou à
Escherichia coli le trio redoutable de
bactéries
même risque un peu plus loin où cette
barre de porc utilisée dans la farce
semble traîner sur un sol noir de crasse
en production donc du coup normalement
les bactéries à la surface elles sont
elles sont tuées
[Musique]
alors vous avez vu les conditions
d'hygiène c'est quoi c'était déplorable
et conditions d'hygiène mais c'est
déplorable moi j'ai vu je vois à côté
une anecdote une fois je me retrouve
dans un magasin une moyenne surface très
connue en France il y en a partout
il y a des poulets à mettre dans une
rose histoire je regarde la redis ce
soir je dis je mets pas les poulets là
dedans et là le gatella le chef il me
dit si si tu peux les mettre s'il y a
pas de problème et tout je fais pas elle
a pas été lavé je suis pas depuis
combien de temps le poissonnier à côté
me dit elle m'avoue lors d'une
discussion qu'elle a pas été lavée
depuis 6 mois non seulement c'était des
poulets polonais qu'on vendait en poulet
français et il a fallu les mettre dans
la rôtissoire
je voulais pas le mettre dedans
j'ai toutes les photos j'ai plus de 100
photos j'ai plus de 50 vidéos
et oui et oui on en est là vous allez
dire je vous je veux alerter les
consommateurs je vous alerter mais
qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire nous en tant
que consommateur on peut faire quoi il y
a un signe il y a quelque chose qu'on
peut faire moi je veux acheter
personnellement
je suis végétarien ah bah ouais parce
que
vous avez été dégoûté
j'étais dégoûté
parce que je me dis si ça serait passé
que dans un magasin mais ça s'est passé
donc de plusieurs magasins quoi
c'est donc qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
comment comment on peut être sûr pour
être sûr je crois que pour choisir sa
viande je pense qu'il faut connaître son
boucher c'est à dire l'artisan le gars
qui est longue quartier et tu vas et tu
vas
manger de la bonne
tout le monde n'a pas les moyens ça
coûte extrêmement cher et énormément de
gens vont acheter en gros dans la bien
sûr ça coûte pas plus cher acier
je peux vous dire que vous prenez du
jambon 4 tranches de jambon vous
l'achetez chez l'artisan d'accord et
vous achetez les mêmes dans le
supermarché il y aura une différence de
prix mais la viande de bœuf ça marche
pas votre démonstration par exemple si
on achète vous savez des steaks hachés
ou de la viande de bœuf en gros pour
toute une famille on peut pas l'acheter
chez le boucher artisanal ça coûte
beaucoup plus cher Laurent ça dépend ça
dépend avec la grandissait à vous poser
vous décrivez une machine infernale que
plus personne ne peut contrôler il y a
pas de sécurité à l'intérieur du magasin
ou d'inscription
internes alors sécurisé interne la DDPP
la Direction Départementale la
protection de la population j'ai déjà
Vertis je les ai assailli quand chercher
dans les magasins il ne se déplaçait pas
il y en a qu'un tu sais déplacé et et là
à ce moment-là il y a un magasin de
moyen de surface très connu en France
qui a pris je sais plus combien de
millions le procès ah ouais d'accord ah
ouais c'est même passé
mental la protection de la population
alors regardez il suffit d'en parler
avec des anciens ouvriers d'usine
agroalimentaire regardez pour comprendre
le désastre un ouvrier ancien employé
d'un grand groupe qui fabrique des
produits que vous avez sans doute déjà
mangé nous a confirmé ces méthodes
c'était il faut faire tourner les
machines on a du retard dépêchez-vous
dépêchez-vous sur le nettoyage il
fallait qu'on produise donc on avait
vraiment pas le choix de bâcler le
nettoyage et parfois en nettoyez pas
certaines machines donc pendant deux
trois jours elles étaient pas nettoyées
et on vaporiser le désinfectant et
parfois on emballait le désinfectant
était même passé chez la machine et vous
recommenciez la production sur cette
ligne là
et voilà et voilà comme le hachoir
il m'arrivait souvent on travaillait
avec des je veux dire avec des collègues
et puis on faisait par exemple les
chipolatas donc les chipolatas sont
composés de porc et de veau on est
d'accord donc on la broyait et après on
faisait le fil américain le film
américain c'est composé de bœuf
uniquement et c'est une sauce américaine
qu'on met par dessus qu'on badigeonne et
bah à ce moment-là les machines
n'étaient pas nettoyées donc les gens
manger du fil américain avec un peu
porte dedans vous imaginez les familles
musulmanes vous imaginez un peu je l'ai
vu je l'ai vu j'ai été viré aussi de un
ou deux magasins en intérim parce que je
ramenais ma grande gueule mais je disais
vous pouvez pas vous allez mettre
quelqu'un sur le chaos et aujourd'hui la
grande distribution en on est là il y en
a pas un pour relever l'autre pour faire
du billet supplémentaire ils sont
les trois extraits qu'on a vu où on voit
quand même qu'il y a des grosses grosses
des gros dérapages ils ont eu la note B
c'est à dire qu'il y a pour le les
contrôleurs il y a pas de fautes très
très grave la trottinette regardez cette
photo que j'avais envie de manger des
choses qui sortent de là donc il y a
aussi du laxisme de ce côté-là
il y a un boucher il y a des bouchers
qui qui twittent également qui disent se
boucher crash sur tous les gens comme
moi qui travaille en grande distribution
qui travaillent en 7 heures par jour à
travailler de vrais produits pour faire
de la qualité pour les clients voilà et
qu'est-ce que vous répondez assez long
alors moi je réponds tout simplement
il y a une vidéo virale qui est sur
Internet qui a fait 320 000 vues je suis
content parce que j'ai pu délier les
langues mais il y a beaucoup de boucher
aussi qui parlent et qui disent et qui
atteste ce que je dis elle est une vidéo
qui est Shiva édition mon éditeur qui
l'a édité tu l'as mis en ligne sur
YouTube et il y a énormément de boucher
qui disent oui Laurent a raison il y en
a qui travaille depuis 30 ans dans la
boucherie qui à qui est-ce medir ah non
mais c'est trop facile je crache pas sur
le métier
simplement pourquoi personne ne veut
parler dans ce métier là pourquoi
personne n'a ramené sa gueule pourquoi
de mais parce que parce qu'aujourd'hui
un Bouchez vie avec 1000 3 essieux de
gagner 1350 euros par mois c'était un
SMIC m'aider à rester debout d'accord et
on est non seulement exploité c'est un
métier où vous faites des heures et les
gars voilà bah ils disent rien c'est
comme c'est comme la salmonelle quand il
a fallu témoigner j'ai demandé à mon
collègue car tirer des rayons les
produits du rayon ah il m'a dit c'est
Laurent non bah non voilà j'y mets-toi
on est là pour protéger les gosses
bah ouais mais ça arrive l'une les
poulets ce que j'ai vu hier dans
l'émission les poulets vous Savoie il
faut savoir que la Pologne il y a
beaucoup de poulet qui sont exportés de
Pologne la Pologne ne maîtrise pas les
bactéries comme les comme la listériose
mais on s'en fout le boucher en grande
distribution touche entre 1600 et 1800
euros net pour 35 heures
moi je touchais 1350 euros donc voilà
j'ai quand même j'ai eu mon sapin en 87
je travaille un peu dans les abattoirs
je travaille en usine à grande
distribution j'ai tout fait c'est vrai
pour ne plus faire ce métier là parce
que c'est un métier que j'ai fait par
des pistes c'est vrai parce que j'aime
bien les animaux parce que voilà mais le
truc c'est que je gagnais 1350 euros net
d'accord alors maintenant peut-être
qu'il y en a qui gagnent 1000 1500 1600
euros peut-être mais je pense pas être
un nul je sais faire le métier de A à Z
je sais je savais admettons dessus tu as
un animal le désossé la carcasse la
désos de A à Z la parée une fois qu'elle
était parée la métorion quoi couper les
steaks faire les rôtis maintenant voilà
maintenant quand il y a des gens qui
disent qu'ils vont reprochent sur les
réseaux de cracher dans la soupe de
vouloir faire du buzz sur votre ancien
métier ce que vous leur répondez
moi je vais je vais te plaire avec eux
je vais dire et je vais je vais les
regarder en face là tout de suite en
disant que ce sont des pourris les
pourris ce sont des pourris parce qu'ils
savent ce qu'ils ont fait et ils savent
ce qu'ils font au quotidien elle
n'allait pas me dire qu'aujourd'hui en
2023 elle aflation qui arrive à
grands-parents en France va accélérer le
processus n'allez pas me dire que ces
gens là n'ont jamais fait de remballe il
suffit tout simplement pour prouver mon
honneur d'aller sous cette vidéo sur
Internet mise en ligne par mon éditeur
pour voir tous les bouchés tu me donnes
raison par contre il y en a d'autres bah
ouais je suis un mytho je suis un mais
voilà c'est comme on m'a dit pourquoi
maintenant au bout de 25 ans tu ramènes
ta gueule bah je la ramène tout
simplement parce que voilà parce qu'il
fallait que je gagne ma vie
parce que moi je veux moi j'ai 57 ans
aujourd'hui je suis un vieux monsieur
mais donc non mais pourquoi le livre
c'est quoi c'est c'est quoi c'est une
façon de dire attention c'est une façon
de mettre en garde ou c'est une façon
aussi de gagner des sous non c'est une
façon je serai pas millionnaire j'en
sais rien ah ouais ouais ouais
non non non moi j'ai mis ma famille en
danger avec ce livre ouais moi je l'ai
mis je peux vous dire il y a eu des
dépôts il y a eu un dépôt de plainte
d'ailleurs qui était déposé dernièrement
bref vous avez des menaces de mort ah
bah oui mais ça a été jusque là moi je
vais vous dire quelque chose moi j'ai
fait ce livre pour avertir que manger de
la viande comme j'ai dit tout à l'heure
c'était il fallait faire très très
attention et dans ce livre je le j'en
parle dans les moindres détails
j'apprends aux gens à choisir leur
viande par rapport à la couleur par
rapport à la traçabilité par rapport à
au goût enfin tout quoi
et dans ce livre ce livret est complet
et dans les moindres détails
je dis voilà quoi je dis Gilbert
vous me le permettrez vous dites ceux
qui continuent à faire ça aujourd'hui ce
qui m'accuse ce sont des pourries mais
excusez-moi ça veut dire que pendant des
années vous avez été un pourri puisque
vous l'avez fait donc ma question elle
est pourquoi quand vous avez vu des
choses terribles aux témoignages et
incroyable pourquoi quand vous alertiez
des gens qui ne venaient pas des
inspecteurs pourquoi vous n'avez pas
alerté les médias pourquoi vous n'avez
pas parlé pourquoi vous êtes restés
passifs
j'ai alerté la DDPP je les ai assez
email j'avertis les médias et il y a des
médias qui sont justement une fois dans
le dernier magasin où j'ai travaillé et
qui ont pris ils ont fait trois
supermarchés
et ils ont pris des produits dans les
trois supermarchés or c'est passé dans
le journal d'ailleurs de France 2
Anne-Sophie Lapix et ils ont retrouvé
des bactéries mille fois supérieur aux
normes européennes parce qu'il ne
voulait pas se déplacer la DDPP ne
veulent pas et les chefs les chefs
bouchés et les chefs bouchés et les
directeurs de magasins ils ferment les
yeux je pense qu'on aura bouché pour
vous répondre demain ça serait bien que
vous veniez demain enfin c'est un
boucher elle a sur les réseaux c'est la
folie
c'est ce que je dis je ne attendez je
j'en parlais avec Monsieur Bernard
ontiel tout à l'heure
certainement qu'il y a des gens
apparemment ils parlent plus pendant la
pub que pendant l'émission
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
certainement qu'il y a des gens bien moi
j'ai des collègues bouchées c'est des
mecs qui sont irréprochables
irréprochables Bernard mais le problème
c'est on a très peu voilà bien sûr voilà
voilà
on en parlera demain
il s'en sort plus mais moi c'est Quito
le gars qui fait des biscuits mais moins
de chocolat qu'avant avant tu en avais
mais il en peut plus le gars les petits
écoliers ils sont ils sont d'accord
c'est vrai Patrick granola je l'ai vu
encore hier il est en rassera total oui
ça veut dire là vous parce que là vous
faites peur à tout le monde donc est-ce
que ça veut dire veut dire que
concrètement vous dites au
téléspectateurs n'allez plus dans votre
supermarché acheter la viande des
supermarchés est-ce que c'est ce que
vous leur dites parce que là vous
paniquez tout le monde et donc voilà
ils vont vous savez que tous les matins
au supermarché le premier travail du
boucher c'est pareil l'avion c'est
d'enlever le noir qui est dessus donc on
parle en église de couteau on part la
viande c'est le premier boulot après
vous faites les chers les sauces c'est
tout mais ce que je dis aux gens c'est
quand ils vont chercher un morceau de
viande au supermarché c'est connaître ou
est né l'animal on peut pas comment il
était nourri comment et de chez qui
parce que
vous avez le boucher il est obligé de
vous montrer la traçabilité il est
obligé
de quelle région
[Rires]